all right places where we would put the
super bowl permanently in honor of the
masters being held every year at augusta
national chris first pick go man i love
the masters too just to let that know my
first pick hands down the granddaddy of
them all that's right i want the rose
bowl that's where i want i want i want
every super bowl at the rose bowl not a
better setting that's not happening i
know with that new stadium in l.a it's a
nice they're gonna have another super
bowl at the rose bowl yeah i i don't
care that's what the you is
my draft all right
it's a great stadium it's one of the
best stadiums in our whole country the
setting is nothing like it i don't know
the grass just looks greener in that
stadium than it does in all the other
stadiums too and when that sun starts to
go down you got the mountains and the
palm trees in the background and that
california setting to me uh that's as
good as it gets the rose bowl you missed
you missed the practical choice the
obvious practical choice miami miami
miami miami every year super bowl should
be in miami without question
non-pandemic years yeah obviously but
miami yeah i i get you i'm i'm a big fan
of that too it's a stadium that you know
has a nice feel for the super bowl and
like we saw two years ago before you
know the world got flipped upside down
it was cool that miami
finally put everything in the same area
in the city to where you know you could
like we were there we could walk
everywhere for the most part you know
you know it was very nice that it wasn't
so spread out i do like that uh my next
one i mean vegas now i mean vegas baby
vegas what i mean that would be a blast
every year you go there you know just
have party if you're a fan all weekend
do all of that and then watch the big
show of the super bowl on sunday and
that's over and you know continue the
party and don't go to sleep like you're
supposed to in vegas and just keep it
rolling vegas seems like a no-brainer
there
you know i i had a great time two super
bowls in miami but
one in new orleans was awesome as well
and new orleans would be my second
choice without question forget about
your two gimme miami gimme new orleans
new orleans was great there's another
one coming up there in the next few
years can't wait for yeah yeah that
that's cool uh i get you the the new
orleans one i mean it's a city that's
it's made to host it it is it's it fits
and i think a lot of people have that
same feeling you do
all right um
well i think for lack of you know better
options i'm going to the place where
we're having the super bowl this year i
got two la ones here i got pasadena in
l.a yeah the new stadium that the
chargers and rams play it's an awesome
stadium
it's made to throw big events like that
it's like covered and everything like
that but yet you're kind of outside
because it's it's like they put a big
roof out over a stadium and didn't fill
in the walls or whatever so
i think that would be my my last choice
there that would be really cool i am
very
very excited for our super bowl this
year on nbc to go out there see that
stadium see how la throws the super bowl
i might have to ask her some tickets for
nbc because i think i got a lot of
family members that want to go if we can
get there
this one is not realistic but it's far
more realistic than the rose bowl which
was your first pick so i'm going to go
ahead and do it and you may regard it as
pandering to our fans
watching on sky sports but i'm going to
go with it i'm going to say london okay
london okay every year i can get behind
that
i
listen purely selfish reasons never been
there can't wait to go it would be the
perfect excuse to go spend a week in
london every year super bowl in london
and i know people in the us would be
pissed sorry london but i i say all the
time
it doesn't matter where the super bowl
is 99.9 of football fans aren't going as
long as it's coming through your tv it
doesn't matter where it's played they
can play it on the moon it doesn't
matter long as it looks like a football
game it doesn't matter where you play it
it's a good it's a good creative pick
i'm i'm not mad at you there they got
some cool stadiums over there too i mean
that's for sure i see some of those
stadiums on the soccer games and i'm
like man i'd love to go in there and see
what that place is like so all right all
right that's good i mean i think my
places are better than yours i don't
care you could get on my rose bowl pick
all you want i like it a lot
yeah i don't
but
i i like going to the super bowl
wherever it is i was even going to
mention indianapolis the one year was in
indianapolis it was awesome now they got
lucky with the weather but india
indianapolis is so convenient it's so it
is it's so easy to get from place to
place and it's got a good feel it can it
can absorb all those people they just
got lucky with the weather yeah could
have been a very long week if it would
have been a blizzard or something like
that because you know the game's in
february
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports